j'ai réalisé la piscine comme prévu j'ai
réalisé le rehaussement des bungalows
j'ai aménagé également au niveau de la
partie au bailliage restauration c'est
au monde bigot tout a été fait respecter
on n'est pas monté contrôler n'est pas
monté voir et avec le rapport que j'ai
reçues il me demande de tout rembourser
les fonds européens
maintenant étant donné que c'est là la
septième gay gestionnaire des fonds
européens à tout moment là me demander
de rembourser les fonds européens
et c'est bien pourquoi je me suis mis à
effectuer une grève de la faim depuis
dimanche soir je n'ai eu aucun élu me
voir alors cessé ou bien il ya un chien
qui était assis là je pense qu'il ya un
lien comme de respect surtout qu'on
parle de la compagnie des porteurs de
projet vous savez quoi mais j'ai déjà
compris et porte le projet en fait les
accompagne au cimetière dans ce pays je
pense que trop c'est trop